aikido
um japanese art of self-defense
i've been giving a lot of thought lately
about uh all the teachers that i've seen
and it suddenly dawned on me that
how things have changed in the in the
modern aikido world
when i teach a seminar it doesn't really
matter where it is in the world
but uh when i showed the students
you start to notice their their style
they have a style and each
each individual if you go to a club
but there's one or two students come
from other clubs organizations
of course you're not introduced to them
when you first bow in
but once you teach the techniques
and you start looking at how they're
doing them you start to get
uh themes of who they follow
what style they follow
and sometimes i'll notice
that they're so clear that they look
like a carbon copy of
their teacher i found this happens more
in the western students
than the japanese students
it does happen in japanese students but
perhaps it was more apparent to me
traveling more in europe than than other
countries
and i would perhaps say to the student
oh i see you
are a follower of
x and
i've normally been correct because they
are so alike
but what i've then been thinking about
recently is
all the top teachers that was in my era
sadly past now there's still yamada
scentsy
i've never trained with tardis scentsy
i've seen him on video and he's still
alive today
i don't know perhaps it's in his 90s but
so a very
uh respected master but the only one
i've
trained with who's alive today that i
that i know of
is yamada sensei in new york
and sadly his top student at the time
was donald weight and he has recently
passed
and it's very sad for me to hear that
because you know you make friends
if you're around long enough you make
friends and these
and you may not have great conversations
on seminars and that you have
conversations
sometimes they can be deep
they may be in drunken stupor but
you make a bond
going back to the look-alikes
so the students are trying to copy the
teacher
and that i think is
is very good 100 would back that
for any student to do but i also
say that uh cytosins he said go and see
as many students
as you can teach as solid teachers as
you can
and i've always been a great believer in
this and it was wonderful when i heard
his words
uh acknowledge that we could
too many teachers think that they can
teach you all you need to know
then you don't need to look outside that
but so let's look at um
these people who are carbon copies of
their teacher
or a particular style
they don't really i think yet know
if that is then the real them
if you walk in any busy street
in my case if i went to cambridge
then there would be tourists from all
over the world
they're walking down the wide paths of
cambridge
in the shopping centers and
apart from perhaps glancing at the odd
face noticing that they're
different another nationality
they don't walk funny or they just
mingle and move the same as anybody else
they pick up their drink if they're
sitting
outside cafe they're eating their food
nothing unusual so
people are in this sense
all acting the same
and yet when we see them on the mat
they're all trying to copy someone but
their minds all thinking of different
things we don't know what each of us are
thinking
while training but we're all thinking of
something
the japanese system i've said before
is about copying what they said they
copy it
but these great masters
who thousands upon thousands of us
have admired taken something from them
gained great knowledge
understanding of technique
perhaps understanding better off one
master than the other
have you any of you seen any of these
top
masters that i'm talking about it
doesn't have to be japanese
it can be western you know america it
doesn't matter where
in the world that you've seen these
masters
but the very best that stand out
do they look like anybody that you know
i haven't seen it
and in nearly 50 years now it's the
first time i've actually thought about
it
i've tried to copy cytoscene c over the
last 20 years of my
following in tilly passed
i've seen students who are a carbon copy
of him
if the distance or your eyesight wasn't
very good you would think that
cytosensei was out there
under the trees with his ken doing
superior
the closer you would get you would find
it was one of his
top third dan japanese students
i won't say his name but he was a carbon
copy
every action that he done
was like a miniature site of scentsy and
it was wonderful to see
but i can't say that i can give that
title to anybody
else so all my period
i've only seen one the western teachers
that are here now teaching
in different parts of the world who
spent time together in iwama
or they were there for a period of time
when another one was there at the same
period
some left some stayed there
they have very similar aikido style
and technical way of doing it but they
don't
look the same so what
is the answer well i think
they've actually found who they are
they don't perhaps even know it
if they took a video out of their friend
who they
spend time with in iwama or you spend
time
with on your tatami you'll know that
you're different than the others they're
different than you
but are the sheer naggers the same the
yikiyos
yes so the technical techniques
we're all taught but we have to adapt
them to
our body ourselves
so when you film yourself as you should
at least once or twice a year
and you look at that film you'll be
criticizing
the points that you have as weaknesses
in your opinion
perhaps you turn your head wrong perhaps
you bring your hand
higher than your head and you should
keep it here
you know there's there's all these
criticisms that you will have
so you know do you
coach you the same way or does do you
make a circle when you coke you
or do you bring your arms straight up
these are characteristics that only you
have
and you have them because they are you
and one day hopefully if you become a
great
influence in the world of aikido
you will have your individuality that
that made this
individuality and for people to want to
know you
perhaps it's your charisma but with
coolisma you still have to have good
eyekiddo
so there's a few thoughts to think about
look at as many teachers as you can take
parts from them that
fit your jigsaw once you make them fit
your jigsaw
and you feel comfortable with it take it
as your own
you won't look like these
individual teachers as a whole
but you may take the whole of what you
absorb over the years
put it into your format
and when you walk down the street you'll
be walking the same as everybody else
not looking out of place but when it
comes to needing
the action or demonstrating on the mat
or being confronted in a situation where
you need your martial art
only then would you become the person
you are
and that's all we should be hoping for
to be
to polish our techniques to do our
basics
but find out who you are and um
one moment you will be yamada sensei the
next moment you may be cytosinsi
nishio sensei asayasenci sugana sensei
tamura sensei norosensi
the the list is endless
there's enough film out there now that
you can see all these teachers
see what you like practice
and practice and practice on what you
like
until you're happy with it
and then go on to the next teacher
until you've built up a chest in your
frame in your body in your mind
build build your aikido
thank you for listening